I refuse to believe Andrew Tate is in
prison no no no no no no
salaam alaikum guys before we go to
Andrew Tate and his tweet about spending
Ramadan alone last year you guys donated
300 000 pounds at Salama organization
and me myself I'm a volunteer at the
organization with that money we printed
10 000 primates we made a website we
teach these people how to pray how to do
wudu how to recite the Quran we do a
one-to-one teaching we have we even have
a sisters team which teaches sisters how
to pray even in Regis Park Mosque we
have a gathering of people who are
coming in their fives and tens and
learning how to praise Allah may Allah
bless you guys for believing in this
project this year we want to carry this
on the link is in the Box description
box please donate to that let's get
straight into the video here is what
Andrew Tate had to say brothers and
sisters in his prison he said
they plot and plan and Allah to plans
and the best of planets is Allah now he
says something retweeting his own tweet
it could be extremely disappointing to
experience my first Ramadan alone but I
understand it will be for a purpose
brothers and sisters is Andrew Tate
really imprisoned and I'm not being a
conspiracy theorist let's listen there
are three people who are imprisoned
which we can look at Andrew take and see
he is literally imprisoned Behind Bars
then there are people like myself and
yourself who are also imprisoned and
that's why the prophet Muhammad's peace
be upon him said that the believer in
the studio will be like a prisoner and
that is the point brothers and sisters
and then we have shaytan who is going to
be imprisoned in Ramadan in our belief
that we believe Satan will be locked up
throughout the month of Ramadan so no
more excuses of blaming Satan shaytan
but the point is the following if you
look at it blown sisters who is really
imprisoned me us or Andrew take our
brother Andrew Tate may Allah release
him plus subhanallah make his efforts
easy we are the ones who are truly
imprisoned you know why because we have
these shackles that are calling us to
the Dunya there was a scholar who came
and they used to say to him why do you
not come and sit in our Gatherings and
we always see you in the graveyards he
said the reason being when I am amongst
you guys all you do is remind me of the
Dunya and when I leave you you speak ill
of me and you backbite me whereas when I
go to the graveyards the people there
remind me of the Hereafter and when I
leave them at least they don't backbite
me brothers and sisters Andrew Tate is
in prison he is there to himself and his
thoughts and that is the point where you
find Allah in that reflection do you
know how many people turn to Islam when
quarantine happened because you are now
away from all the things that will
disturb you and that is why Islam came
we are the ones who are truly imprisoned
we are the ones when we go out we have
we see Haram we indulge in Haram there
are hundreds if not thousands of things
on our phones to the Billboards to the
advertisements on the bus calling us to
Haram there are people in our Lives who
calls us to Haram
who is really imprisoned I believe this
Ramadan it is indeed Andrew Tate who is
truly free and the rest of us are
imprisoned and in shackles
and we need to break those shackles and
I brought those chapters when I came to
Islam and found my true Freedom when I
enslaved myself to the one who created
me before my masters and my fake gods
were the opposite gender clubs money
partying so I believe no I refuse to
believe Andrew Tate is in prison no no
no no no no
hate is truly free having a connection
with his word inshallah why we are
imprisoned but you can make the most of
this Ramadan brothers and sisters make
the most out of it indeed Allah plans
like he said and he is the best of
planets to have that connection and Free
Yourself
that's all I'm going to say brothers and
sisters may Allah free
those who are falsely accused
do not forget to have that connection
with the Quran brothers and sisters the
Quran should be in your life daily
download the qurani app and have that
connection brothers and sisters it
reminds you daily how much you can how
much you've been reading you has an
encounter you can even have competition
with your family and friends that's all
I'm going to say brothers and sisters
may Allah bless you inshallah and truly
free us from the imprisonments of the
sins that we are in
and to his obedience